bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video
oggi sono sommesi ha però non è una
storia lunga quella che farò
si chiama get out informi knicks
praticamente consiste inizio da zero
praticamente è una storia completamente
diversa rispetto alle altre
ve lo spiego durante il caricamento ne
approfitto praticamente consiste nel
liberarmi devo riuscire a uscire da una
stanza nella quale sono chiuso
utilizzando tutto quello che ho a
disposizione per poter uscire in quattro
minuti quindi ho soltanto quattro minuti
di tempo qua c'è mezza scritta vedo non
so perché ma veyron importa quindi o
quattro minuti di tempo per poter
fuggire prima che dovrò utilizzare
qualsiasi tutte le risorse che trovo
attorno a me nella stanza è un po
enigmatica nel senso che devo fare in
fretta a capire che cosa devo fare per
uscire ma l'avete consigliata voi qua
devo correre subito
ok perfetto con ricordi carico a ricordi
ti odio ok tempo rimanente ok perfetto
da questo momento o quattro minuti
rimanenti per poter uscire di qua ora
innanzi tutto qua
ok la chiave l'ho già presa
bene così stanno tentando di sfondare oh
mio dio perfetto non non so cosa devo
fare allora uscita principale perfetto
c'è una leva che presumo non funzionerà
infatti
ok qualcosa devo fare l'isico casa
un'altra porta
che non si apre forse si apre con la
chiave ok
ap di cazzo non si apre niente sfonda
armadio è veramente ragazzi mi avete
detto che è difficilissima perché ci
avete provato in tutti i modi cioè non
so che tipo è vero ha detto però chi di
voi è stato mi ha detto che ci ha
provato in tutti i modi e non c'è
riuscito ma ragazzi stavolta c'è fa vj e
la porta si apre incredibile senza la
chiave che cazzo serve st chiave ok
inutile
è bloccato ha bisogno di qualcosa per
forzarla dai
forse quando infilarci la chiave no se
grande allora questo dovrebbe essere
meccanismo finale per aprire la porta
però c'è qualcosa qui dietro lo vedo
devo riuscire a spostare la libreria
come calzona sposto la libreria
ok qualcosa cos'è quello
c'è un qualcosa sotto
il quadro martello si toglie il quadro
fantasma
ok
martello sfonda tutto niente
ok non si sfonda niente ragazzi sono
solo nella merda perché non sto capendo
cosa devo fare forse devo sbloccare
questo sì grande però non funzionano
ancora
non funziona perché manca energia ma
anche ancora una chiave che troverò
nell'altra stanza presumibilmente
che troverò qua dentro probabilmente
però non si sa
merda ok ragazzi c'è un problema forse
c'è qualcosa sul lampadario dammi quadro
subito
vai
ok non c'era niente si sa
beh ragazzi sono non so cosa devo fare
ho già fatto un bel po per essere primo
tentativo è però non so vi giuro non so
cosa devo fare
scoprile devo riuscire a passare qui
sotto il successo non far passare quadro
vai
mai niente non c'è verso passo non è
tipo da la libreria di dexter che tiri
fuori un libro e si apre no vero
devo pregare creda che il creatore di
questa mappa conosca dexter il modo che
ci abbia azzeccato ma non mi pare
ok no prova a prendere una sedia datemi
una sedia quanto manca che non ho visto
non mi ricordo più quanto manca ma ci
provo lo serve la forza un minuto cazzo
dai dai dai dai dai
cine merda eh sì però stai ferma anche
tu no niente non si è perso
vai
ragazzi merda si apre niente perfetto
ipotesi completamente andato a [ __ ]
non si apre non so cosa fare ragazzi non
ho idea aiuto
stanno per sfondare oddio oddio aiuto
ok perfetto mi raggiungono forse la
sedia aiutami
difenderò con tutto quello che posso
c'è qualcosa lassù tipo sopra l'altra
porta
vedo tipo qualcosa sopra l'altra porta
ragazzi ok prova di andarci 3 2 1
vai no ok perfetto no
oddio un apprendista seria kyosanto
calmi santissimo
dio mio che violenza
quanti siete è giusto per chiedere
raga ci provo anche se ormai è finito il
tempo ai a ok non ci provo questo quarzo
fermo questa è una situazione epica
ragazzi allora devo riuscire ad arrivare
alla porta
ci prova anche se non ci riuscirò mai
poi ci provano si sa mai
vai attacca temi
34 a cipro adesso dai forza carri chiede
addio addio
ok va bene
si sono di nuovo qui beh adesso so cosa
fare almeno prendo a chiave ti porta a
meno
mi sono salvato la partita così non
devono iniziare ogni volta tutto da capo
finco la chiave ci vuole martello non so
dovere mastella mi ricordo più dovere
martello ragazzi a sia dietro il quadro
allora fin qua c'ero arrivato abbastanza
facilmente qua dentro non c'è niente
la sopra dicevo mi sembrava di aver
visto qualcosa adesso controllo allora
adesso abbiamo tutto il tempo e sappiamo
cosa fare non posso usare oggetti vita
perché eri fumato qualcosa
il problema è che prima di entrare lì
non è che c'è qualcosa qui sopra si sa
mai che provo
ok non c'è niente
l'unico problema ragazzi la libreria
però non è messa a caso vero perché
l'altra libreria serve per essere tolta
l'altra libreria serve per scorrere le
va bene questa che cosa serve però non è
che li condurrà qua sono ragazze cielo
questo libro però mi sono fissato
scusatemi un attimo
devo devo aprire la libreria in qualche
modo non so come però questa si può o
dio lo sa chi è
non ci credo non lo avevo visto prima
ragazze l'avevo visto ma non siamo
affatto il caso
ok ok due minuti ragazzi ce la posso
fare
chiave forse c'è qualcosa di possenti
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce veloce veloce e veloce
velocissimo globale ok librerie tutta
caso vero xvi prego in cinese che non ci
sia nulla di nascosto qui perché non
sapere che cosa fare non avrei tempo un
minuto ragazzi ce la posso fare credo in
me stesso chiave come no
ppa bpa per il culo
ah no forse ed utilizzata qua ok ok dai
che ci siamo vai
vai su tutti 2 giu non lo so questo
farmaco perfetto aperto qualcosa ho
aperto questa no ho aperto la l'uscita
spero
[Musica]
sì
ciò ha favorito è il 3 porte che cazzo
servivano a vigere la vj secco secondo
tentativo
incredibile secondo tentativo ragazzi
probabilmente una persona normale ci
sarebbe riuscito al primo ma non importa
per me è già un traguardo vabbè era una
mappa veloce veloce giusto perché era
carina a farla avere una mappa veloce da
fare è giusto perché era carino farla
era bellissima l'idea vi lascio non la
dean descrizione provata dai
servizi sul video lasciato mi piace per
quanto fosse breve il video per ora
quattro minuti più o meno un po di più
quindi non è che potevo fare chissà cosa
ma se è piaciuto vi lasciato mi piace un
commento qui sotto lasciato mi piace
anche sto facendo facebook che ha
trovati descrizione ci vediamo prossimo
video dai ragazzi